in 2018 these are the films that got our
butts in the seats and then sent us home
with our wallets empty and our hearts
unfulfilled these films were the worst
of 2018 there may not be a major
Hollywood film with worse timing than
Death Wish a remake of the classic 1974
Charles Bronson film the 2018 version
features Bruce Willis is an everyday Joe
who takes up arms to clean up the
streets of Chicago after his daughter is
assaulted and his wife is murdered by
thugs the notorious Eli Roth delivered a
picture that landed squarely in the
middle of the real-life debate over guns
in America and suffered immensely for it
critics took note of the film's poor
timing having already been pushed back
from a fall 2017 release after the Las
Vegas mass shooting that claimed 58
lives but all that aside the potentially
nasty fun of a revenge flick simply
failed to materialize nearly as well as
the Bronson original and it was thought
of that way it could be truly part of
the most ridiculously popular multimedia
property to ever come from the world of
Twilight fan fiction the third
installment in the Fifty Shades series
finalizes a franchise that never found
critical acclaim
despite posting insane box office
numbers Fifty Shades breeds critics
didn't even hold back a little the
famously colorful Rex Reed said it was
grotesquely mindless and inescapably
boring while it continues to ignore
motivation character development logic
and narrative cohesion Reed gave the
movie one star but it was apparently
earned by the movies furniture the few
positive reviews tended to highlight its
merits as unintentional satire rather
than any redeeming qualities it might
otherwise have had but there is one
great thing about Fifty Shades free it
marks the end of the series
you know that don't you expectations
were sky high for director Ava Duvernay
is adaptation of the classic 1962 young
adult novel a wrinkle in time with an
amazing cast attached the film looked to
be another winner for Disney but
unfortunately it fell surprisingly flat
with critics posted flat box-office
receipts to match negative reviews
focused on the disappointment sure to be
felt by fans of the novel as the
adaptation didn't match the source
materials tone spliced today's Stephen
Silver argued it's based on one of those
novels that's long been described as
unadaptable only to result in a movie
that proved such naysayers right
Sanae Fellowes called it a film that
does not stop feeling generic you're
kidding do I look like I'm kidding a
little I'm not I'm not it seems that it
wasn't just one thing that went wrong
but if do Bernays stellar past work is
any indication she should bounce back
quickly it's hard to deny that Amy
Schumer has had a hard time hitting her
stride with her film projects aside from
her promising 2015 debut in the Judd
Apatow directed trainwreck this year's I
feel pretty in which Schumer is an
average-sized woman who awakens from an
accident believing she's a supermodel
seemed to sport the perfect premise for
Schumer's brand of comedy but it largely
turned out to be a swinging a mess The
New Yorker proclaimed that the film
essentially wasted its entire cast from
Schumer to Naomi Campbell Michelle
Williams and veteran actress Lauren
Hutton and went on to call it a painful
unaware condescension masquerading as
encouragement I want to punch you right
in your dumb face right now most other
critics were no kinder agreeing that the
movie felt pandering and insincere and
that the comedic moments were just
playing tone-deaf
perhaps Apatow the only director who's
proven himself capable of successfully
harnessing Schumer's vibe on the big
screen should give her a call because
the response to I feel pretty has been
nothing short of ugly based on the
dangerously irresponsible real-life
action park and featuring johnny
Knoxville and his usual roundup of
friends the movie action point seemed
like surefire comedy gold tailor-made
for jackass like studs
the movie was the perfect framing device
for humiliating pratfalls and bodily
injury but it arrived in theaters only
to fall right on its face many critics
found action point to be way too soft
and safe complaining that the whole
thing was unworthy of its death-defying
inspiration Reno news and review critic
Bob grim who'd survived the actual
action park as a child called it
basically an insult to the legend of
action Park or death Park as we like to
call it it's a rare case of the Jackass
crew not going far enough they've all
been in the business of abusing
themselves for the better part of two
decades so here's hoping they can give
us at least one more stellar outing
without killing themselves fans could be
forgiven for approaching Slender Man
with a healthy amount of trepidation
plot details had been kept tightly under
wraps during the film's production and
when the film hit theaters it became
clear why we hadn't heard much what
little plot there was in slender and
just seemed way too thin
critics flogged the picture for its
non-existent story and lack of any
genuine scares cinema crazed nailed down
all the film's problems with one
sentence deep down beats the heart of a
great horror movie but it's lost in
cheap jump scares bad CGI and heavy
cribbing from Nightmare on Elm Street
and the ring more than one reviewer
noted the film's proximity to the
real-life recent Slender Man stabbing
with some even making the case that the
film exploits the tragedy but at the end
of the day slender man's worst crime was
just being boring the happy time murders
seemed like it had an inspired comedic
premise as a sort of mashup between
Sesame Street gone wrong and who framed
roger rabbit the film stars melissa
mccarthy as a human police detective in
a world where people coexist with living
puppets she and her puppet partner are
tasked with getting to the bottom of a
series of murders its premise with the
potential to be a raunchy edgy comedy
unfortunately the film failed to deliver
the laughs the always blunt Peter
Travers of Rolling Stone called it a
toxic botch job which deserves an early
death by box office
Sarah Mars of laney gossip called it too
boring and mediocre to be the worst
movie ever
puppet based raunchy humor isn't
impossible but this film just couldn't
crack the code and also managed to
deliver yet another starring vehicle
unworthy of McCarthy's talents the films
of the conjuring universe have never
done anything less than gangbusters at
the box office
even when nabbing mixed critical reviews
since the first appearance of the
demonic nun VALIC and the conjuring 2
fans have been clamoring for a film
centered on the terrifying figure but
her starring turn has unfortunately put
the filmmakers in need of paying penance
while critics generally considered the
film to be technically well acted and
well-made nothing could save it from
giant gaps in logic and a meandering
narrative structure many observers also
took the film's task for its heavy
reliance on cliche said the Seattle
Times Soren Anderson entombed the
audience is in horror movie cliches the
moments don't build to any sort of
sustained narrative momentum it's so
choppy and predictable that it becomes
laughable despite all that another
hugely profitable sequel is probably in
the works right now maybe with a scarier
story to tell
fans of sci-fi 80s monster action were
psyched about the announcement of Shane
Black's suburbia set the predator blacks
action bonafides have never been in
question
the trailers looked fresh and funny and
it seemed highly unlikely that anyone
would drop the ball sure black is
incapable of making a bad looking film
and he didn't disappoint here but even
his gifts couldn't overcome a
surprisingly bland script and
undisciplined plotting Brandon Katz of
The Observer called it a thorough grab
bag of averageness made worse by its
distinct lack of distinction to come and
get us a little his peers on the other
hand focused on the film's over reliance
on zippy one-liners and emulating ATSB
movies in the worst possible ways it
added up to a shocking miss from a
filmmaker who seemed to have it all
together Clint Eastwood has a pretty
good track record as a director and an
even better one as a director of
historical dramas so expectations were
high for the 1517 to Paris the true
story of a trio of American soldiers who
thwarted a terrorist
back on the train while traveling in
Europe the actual soldiers involved in
the incident were even recruited to play
themselves in the movie
unfortunately real-life heroes don't
necessarily make good actors according
to critics the New Republic wrote about
all three stars they're all handsome but
just appalling actors this disjuncture
isn't possible to forget while watching
the film and it's very uncomfortable
patting out a relatively brief incident
to the length of a whole film resulted
in two-thirds of the film's run time
devoted to tedious exposition while the
centerpiece action sequence earned
praise everything surrounding it
disappointing the 1517 to Paris arrived
at the station greeted by wildly
indifferent audiences forever my girl is
the story of a country music star who
returns home for a funeral only to face
the lost love he left behind if that
description strikes you is overly
familiar and formulaic you're not alone
critics couldn't help but note that
forever failed to even clear the bar set
by the wildly popular weepers based on
Nicholas Sparks novels not really my cup
of tea
no offense taken the film seemed to
bring out the snark and practically
every critic who viewed it the San
Francisco Chronicle got very specific
it's a poorly made film with rough edits
distracting staging and plot contrivance
--is that can be predicted to the moment
there's an almost startling lack of
chemistry between the leads and it says
if every third scene was cut out
randomly the picture only managed a 16
million dollar haul during its
theatrical run Winchester sounded like
the kind of horror slam-dunk that comes
along rarely a supernatural Fright Fest
based on the insanely spooky true story
of Sarah Winchester who built the mother
of all haunted houses starring Helen
Mirren in the title role the stars were
all aligned so how did it go so terribly
wrong critics agreed that it represented
a forgettable wail of a missed
opportunity Peter Travers of Rolling
Stone heaped scorn all over the film
saying it shouldn't happen to anyone
much less a dame not a movie of such
barrelling awfulness as Winchester which
strands the great Helen Mirren and a
gothic house of cards that collapses on
actors and audiences alike the film's
writer-director duo the spirit brothers
were taken to task for choosing
jump-scares over
a sphere and one review went so far as
to call Mirren's presence in the film
and explicable with Winchester the
spirits delivered arguably the most
disappointing misfire of the year if
this is your first time hearing of
action comedy gringo you're not alone
the film flopped spectacularly grossing
only about eleven million dollars
worldwide despite an insanely
accomplished cast the story of a
mild-mannered American who goes breaking
bad on a trip south of the border the
sophomore feature from veteran stunt
coordinator Nash Edgerton failed to
score with critics while general
audiences were simply unaware of his
existence not that this was necessarily
a bad thing rolling stone's David beer
said it can't decide whether it wants to
be magnificently toxic or merely
mediocre this is a romp that's keen on
going nowhere and slowly baby most of
the critical venom was reserved for its
unfunny contrived mess of a screenplay
on which the film's amazing cast was
apparently completely wasted director
Robert Zemeckis has given us such
beloved films as the Back to the Future
series Forrest Gump and cast away and
his year-end release welcome to Marwin
had prestige picture written all over it
it's a fictionalized account of the life
and work of Marc Hogan King who builds a
scale model of a world war 2 era belgian
town in his backyard featuring Steve
Carell in the lead
Zemeckis film took a huge aesthetic
gamble by being set partially inside the
fictional town Carol's performance drew
fire for its lack of nuance and Zemeckis
took his share of hits for offering
one-dimensional female characters and
failing to inject the story with genuine
emotion the CGI dolls left some viewers
stranded in the uncanny valley and
though most critics agreed the film was
well-intentioned it all added up to a
Titanic misfire the post-apocalyptic
thriller mortal engines a stonking to
Cepeda due to the involvement of
producer peter jackson and director
christian rivers a longtime jackson
associate in the movies world gigantic
cities on wheels roamed the landscape in
search of resources
while some critics praised the film's
world-building even the positive notices
lamented it's stitched together
derivative story and the critics that
pan the film panned it extra hard the
New York Post's Sarah Stewart called it
quote a wearying blast of CGI and genre
cribbing which pillages better movies
for spare parts she also pointed out
that even the soundtrack by junkie XL is
highly reminiscent of the composer's
work on Mad Max fury road she wasn't the
only observer to point out that mortal
engines seemed to invite comparison to
that unassailable classic although some
were slightly more succinct said splice
today's Stephen Silver it's been a long
time since Peter Jackson last made a
good movie and the dry spell continues
with mortal engines which answers a
burning question what if Mad Max fury
road had sucked john c reilly and will
ferrell can be a formidable comedic duo
as we've seen in multiple films
unfortunately holmes and watson brought
that streak to a screeching halt
one of the worst reviewed films of the
year holmes and watson literally saw
audiences walking out of the theater the
vast majority of critics were none too
pleased that they were professionally
obligated to sit through the whole thing
what have you done with shut off
why Watson I never left the problems
permeated the production from it's
terribly unfunny screenplay to its
direction and editing which one reviewer
called the worst of any film released in
2018 the flick was lambasted for its
lazy humor and for wasting the talents
of Riley Ferrell and its entire
supporting cast here's hoping that Riley
and Ferrell can bounce back with a movie
that audience is actually what to spend
their money on
me too better luck next year Hollywood